concrétiser un projet demandent souvent
du temps et des moyens financiers
importants dans le domaine de la petite
enfance le département a choisi depuis
maintenant trois ans de soutenir les
projets liés au développement des
maisons d'assistants maternels comme
celle de café vanille à être salée on a
étudié le projet et c'était un super
projet donc on a soutenu et en un site
justement les mamans à ouvrir des
membres à s'associer avec des personnes
qui veulent travailler parce que c'est
quand même un ami un super métier et
individuellement peut-être plus
compliqué mais en s'associant ensemble
c'est c'est peut-être plus facile de
faire aboutir un projet ça fait à peu
près un an et demi on a travaillé dessus
sachant que c'était pas évident parce
que ont travaillé déjà et du coup avoir
du temps libre pour concrétiser notre
cause et il fallait vraiment jongler
mais on a travaillé on va dire même le
week-end on avait plus de nos congés
personnels avec plus de causer personne
n'est plus du week-end est passé à des
réunions there is no d'information on a
suivi des formations on a passé notre
diplôme premiers secours le ps sort avec
une capacité d'accueil de 16 enfants et
une demande très élevée cette 24eme
homme affiche déjà complet
ce nouveau dispositif regroupant jusqu'à
quatre assistants maternels propose un
mode de garde plus ou plus par an
ça m'a aidé parce que je recherchais du
travail au début et après du coup quand
j'ai eu mon travail beige jeu comme je
connaissais déjà anthony donc ça maïmat
il m'a proposé de déposer james a
la manne et du coup ben voilà même je
pense que franchement c'est un super
projet qu'ils ont fait ça aide les
parents vraiment parce que ben moi je
trouve qu'ils sont des assistants
maternels en or pour l'éveil des enfants
le
la même café vanille et quand même
intéressante parce que c'est un groupe
d'enfants qui est nombreux ils sont à 16
ans tous l'équipe fait des activités
régulièrement les enfants entre eux du
coup il ya des interactions cas moi je
vois la différence c'est l'éveil qui est
beaucoup plus rapide chez gabriel que
chez d'autres enfants qui sont suivis
par l'assistante maternelle sol
installée dans une maison de centimètres
carrés dans les hauteurs d'étang salé
valérie annecy marie josée et anthony
porteurs du projet ont dû adapter ce
local aux différentes normes de sécurité
m tout autant au niveau incendie donc
les extincteurs au niveau de sécurité
barrières les caches coin sur les
meubles les barrières pour éviter que
les enfants aillent donc d'autres salles
après on a donc tout ce qui dit le sol
souple donc pour éviter que l'enfant se
comptent vraiment qu'ils se fassent mal
à titre volontariste le département
apporte son soutien technique et
financier aux créateurs de man afin de
favoriser l'embauché d'assistants
maternels et d'augmenter la capacité
d'accueil des enfants à la réunion ça
permet aux assistantes maternelles
agrées de réfléchir à un projet
d'accueil commun et ça leur permet de
d'avoir plus de facilités en termes
d'embûches puisque elles vont
s'installer à un endroit où il ya de la
demande que le département a décidé
d'accompagner financièrement les
porteurs de projet m'a notamment en
accordant une subvention de 4000 euros
par mam à gré est aussi de permettre aux
assistantes maternelles de pouvoir
solliciter un prêt ça permet de faire
les travaux de financer les premiers
travaux pour pouvoir ensuite obtenir
l'agrément de plus près de 150
assistants maternels bénéficient chaque
année d'une formation gratuite organisée
et prise en charge par le conseil
général
l'objectif est de surmonter la
problématique de la garde d'enfants
rencontrées par les parents
j'ai au manque de structures adaptées et
donc deux places